[Musik]
was genau steckt eigentlich hinter dem
begriff populismus die oft negativ
genutzt wird was macht einen populisten
aus wichtig es gibt nicht den populismus
keine einheitliche definition oft ist
der begriff und präzise und wert geladen
meistens ist damit eine strategie
gemeint also eine bestimmte art politik
zu machen
sie zeichnet sich dadurch aus dass die
stimmungen des volkes aufgreift und sie
verschärft durch dramatisierung der
politischen lager soll die gunst der
massen gewonnen werden dabei betonen sie
den vermeintlichen unterschied zwischen
der elite und dem volk populisten
behaupten sie vertreten die meinung des
einfachen volkes gegen die da oben das
sind politiker intellektuelle die eu und
auch die medien populisten geben vor
dass sie als einzige genau wissen was
die menschen wirklich wollen
das volk sind sie dabei als eine
homogene einheit an in der alle das
gleiche wollen oft konzentrieren sich
populisten deswegen auch nur auf ein
bestimmtes thema in ihrer politik
populismus gibt es dabei sowohl aus dem
politisch linken als auch rechten lager
während sich sprache und rhetorik auf
denen sind ihre ideen und feindbilder
sehr unterschiedlich unabhängig ob links
oder rechts zu sprechen die gefühle und
sorgen und nöte der bevölkerung an und
schüren ängste ihre mittel sind dabei
emotionalisierung und gezielte
provokationen populisten wollen
komplizierten politischen sachverhalten
mit vermeintlich einfachen lösungen
begegnen
doch so einfach ist das nicht in unserer
globalisierten welt gibt es für
schwierige probleme kein simples
patentrezept wie seht ihr das wie
gefährlich ist populismus für unsere
demokratie kommentiert unter diesem
video